if I did what most people did I wouldn't
have the money because I didn't make
that much money to invest in Twitter and
Facebook I wouldn't had it I would had
25 pairs of Nikes and a Mercedes to meet
you hello how are you nice to meet you
good how's your day good 12 o'clock
midnight I believe I message mail you on
getting new IDs that and I thought that
the best chance to meet you and discuss
the challenges which I feel get some
your peace of mind in terms of how do
you see sales I know by heart your sales
guy right and there's so much going on
in the market right now to be relevant
in the next five years and I'm selling
technology which basically means that
you know it's gonna be an interesting
journey for me especially with the AI
going to the beach and everything yes so
you know I don't know let's start
backwards the machine learning and AI
think is very important because anytime
there's new technologies that people
think are going to replace humans it
always takes so much longer than people
think like the thought that machines are
gonna replace salespeople in the next
decade is virtually impossible you know
like there's you know which has to
happen for that to be a reality
including you know the social aspects
like human that's where technologists
get confused is the technology is there
but the adoption isn't because the
adoption is emotional taking the risk to
fire half your sales staff to let
machine you know here's what doesn't
work being a salesperson who spends
their entire day cold email
people on LinkedIn is probably a
vulnerable skill because the machine can
do that going and golfing or having a
glass of wine or building relationships
as a salesperson is not something
machines replacing anytime and that is
where most of the magic is in sales
having a good product knowing your
product and then building an actual
relationship where people trade on
humanity not on data so I think sales is
going to be a very very down the long
line thing that's disrupted by
technology itself now selling technology
is interesting because sometimes your
product becomes irrelevant and you're
selling something you don't believe in
that to me is the biggest fear and
that's why if you've noticed cuz it
sounds like consume my content
I've been spending more time talking
about selling stuff you believe in I
have sales people selling me stuff I
asked one question and they break and
they break because they already know
they're in trouble because they think
I'm smart to know I'm smart and two they
get exposed for selling something they
don't believe in but they've been doing
it for nine years and they know the
product but the market moved I don't
sell social media at vaynermedia I sell
attention so I'm not pushing Twitter and
Facebook I'm pushing whatever I believe
has the attention at an underpriced
level so for me it's always gonna be
easy to sell vaynermedia because I'm not
tied down to anything and so that's
where it gets tough I have the luxury of
driving the company towards products and
features and things to sell that are
relevant when you work somewhere if your
company doesn't do that I mean they're
stuck if you're selling desktop
computers if you're competing with
Amazon Cloud if you're if there's been a
SAS product that's been released and
you're building Enterprise websites and
you're competing at Squarespace or
WordPress or Shopify or Magento that's
tough so I think the biggest thing that
I would say is make sure you're never in
a position where you're not selling
something you believe in that's what
stuff and so what that requires is
having your feet in the business
that you do but your head in so I think
of it as feet head and heart my head is
always looking at where I'm going my
feet are always where I have to be and I
try to hope that I can have my heart
match with my head because if your heart
and head are matched you have a big
chance of winning if you love it and you
know it's smart hundred percent all of a
sudden when your heart is leading your
head instead of your head to your heart
you're putting yours
you know this is why I always try to get
people to change jobs because I tell
them start with your heart take a little
less money like but if you love eSports
if you love video games
well that's heart if you use your head
you're like eSports is growing that's
great
if your heart is in typewriting your
head is gonna say no that's not where
the world is going now you have to make
a decision right but I'm much happier
with the person that goes with their
heart and does top writing and lives a
more humble life than what I think most
people do which is they go with their
heart the head which a lot of times is
attached to their pocket but their
hearts not in it and then they live that
life that so many people live that is
the worst life which is you're stuck
paying your mortgage and your bills and
taking care of your family but you're
miserable 40 to 70 hours a week minimum
ly and then in your head you're
miserable 144 hours a week okay yes I
was watching a few videos and you say
you're in Mumbai
yes nine years back mm-hmm
I was just seeing the number of views on
that around 700 views probably there at
that time probably it was around 200 use
probably find it the views added in the
last three four years makes sense it
must have been a difficult journey for
you not really because I love the
journey more than the results my friend
I like it better when I have 200 use I
don't like what's happening now
that's the fundamental difference you
want to know what the difference is that
question and that answer my favorite
times is when nobody knows who I am and
when I'm struggling cuz I love that part
if you notice when I started winning in
the wine business I went into this
business my friend um listen I think I'm
about 36 months away from doing
something drastic and doing something
completely different that people going
to tell me the problem is this chapter
elevated me so much that I'm worried
that the next thing I'm already gonna
people are just gonna say he's gonna win
I prefer the negative I feel like I
might move to NY where nobody knows me
just to just to have that feeling it
wasn't difficult it wasn't difficult at
all and that's what I'm trying to push
people pour it when you love it when
it's your heart driving you
it's the most fun it's liberating like
as long as you're paying for your
family's existence then you know and to
me that can be as simple as roof and
food people get too fancy they buy an
expensive car in a second home and now
they're stuck because they have a
mortgage and I have to pay for those
things no I'm glad you asked that
question next
cuz it allowed me to really make you
understand the only part I like is the
struggle I don't like the ad Marie I
mean look this feels incredible for
people to feel like you're helping them
but the reason I want admiration and
fame is because I think I can help
it's a sense of responsibility it is not
a to me it is I'm not doing what I'm
doing right now out of the narcissistic
vanity reasons I'm doing it out of a
sense of responsibility which is I have
an ability to connect with people and if
they connect with me I'm gonna teach
them very good values and for me
especially excuse young male and young
males can go down a very bad path very
quickly and so if I can get them I still
have that star power to get them
attracted and they like it and it's
macho and it's alpha but underneath my
facade is a purity that most of my
competitors don't play with and I feel
like that is my greatest impact on
society like if I can do this for next
45
years if I can impact the generation of
young men to do good things I can have a
real impact others I'm living on 26th I
wish I could get a chance to visit the
synergy global mmm next weekend alone
it's a big event big day a marriage yeah
so as long back my brother gifted me
this book for disciplines of execution
I'm big on execution of very bad
strategy that's set for me for me right
yeah
what I feel is uh I can work towards
thing and that's a reason by the way you
know it's apologized to cut you off your
self-awareness is the ultimate strategy
you know it's funny to hear you say I'm
bad at strategy and I'm bad at plenty of
things you're bad at MicroStrategy the
fact that you even know that means
you're winning the most important
strategy game there is strategies in is
an insight if we don't have insights on
ourselves and who we are we can't put
ourselves in a position to succeed so
you might be bad at some micro strategy
but the fact that you even understand
that means you're winning the macro
strategy game and that's the unlocks do
you have an interesting assignment
though it's gonna be in Australia so
it's a different world altogether
you guys are gonna move yeah
congratulations
yeah what city I'm sorry what Sydney
Sydney you've been before know amazing
it's an amazing city how long you gonna
be there I don't know how beautiful he
is you excited are you gonna miss home
good good awesome I'm gonna be in Sydney
in a week or two
oh yeah so what are you know Selman so
I'm responsible for Oracle technology
database yes
software yes intelligence I know it so
our goal itself is transforming and
Devon le to do advertisement
now they have a social presence
themselves right and so for me it's
going to be very interesting because we
are getting into a different market all
together the SME business or always you
come in here I space we were always
working to fortunate find it companies
now we are talking to startups getting
them on and I think I'm understand of
the technology and what was excited but
so you know one question which I have in
my mind which I really wanted to ask you
is see I'm very high on ambush okay
how's your paint house how's your
patience ambition - how old are you I'm
training you know baby okay hello why do
I have this fantasy of not working a
full-time job or a business and raise
you guys gonna start a few have a family
you're gonna start up a mic I mean maybe
that's I mean there's a million reasons
why why not so what's the question so I
don't know if I should go all into my
abortion sure but just have but it
doesn't mean you need to quit your job
all in to your ambitions may look like
this I'm gonna work really great at work
for next 10 years and you're gonna look
at your wife and say okay and we're
gonna be smart and we're gonna save even
more than normal
we're gonna leave even more humbly
because what do we need and that's gonna
allow us to save five thousand ten
thousand fifty god I don't know your
business I don't need to know your
business but if you save even ten
thousand dollars for over ten years that
you would have just spent a dumb [ __ ]
that's a hundred thousand dollars it's
enough to start a small business people
don't get caught up in the numbers get
caught up in the game you know just back
to that last answer I gave you if your
ambition is to work for yourself there's
a very big difference between working
for yourself and working for yourself
and making 40 million dollars a year you
can work for yourself they can work for
themselves at a very low number you
could it's keeping things in budget you
need to decide what you guys need
now listen I would argue a lot of
families need two very nice vacations I
understand that somebody may need a
fancy car because they're insecure and
that makes them feel good I'm okay with
anything I just think that you don't
need everything you think you need so to
me it's not about being making $400,000
a year and living in a studio like
you're poor but it is looking at what
220 thousand dollars a year in making
salary like that and living like it's
150 or making eighty seven and living
like it's 62 I mean do you know what
most people do they make 115 and live
like that's 200 and then depth and
hallways through for what to look cool
with everybody else and that's and
that's not even factoring in if the
economy gets bad do you know what
happens to people when they make a
hundred twenty-five thousand a year and
live like it's 200 thousand when the
economy goes bad
yeah we've been living a long time now
you guys haven't even felt a bad economy
globally right you are a baby
right that's which is very so I don't
know I'm just even looking at your body
got language like just don't think you
need anything I wish I documented my 20s
and 30s you know I didn't I mean we were
I was 36 years old living renting
renting a two-bedroom apartment 36
and I believe that if I did what most
people did I wouldn't have the money
because I didn't make that much money to
invest in Twitter and Facebook I
wouldn't had it I would had 25 pairs of
Nikes and a Mercedes and that changed my
life at some level but really never it
didn't you know what's funny if I'm
getting being serious it didn't change
my life I'm still sitting with all the
equity I mean I sold Twitter but I gotta
go I know I gotta catch a flight I got
to go to Singapore but I wanted to sneak
in this meeting thank you so much it's
such a pleasure I hope you got some
value out of it oh good
awesome blog I really really really
really really hope you listen to every
word of that meeting I thought it was I
could tell by Dee rocks reaction there
was some good stuff going on so the
advice I'm giving this lovely couple is
probably the vice that 95% of you need
it so I hope you enjoy it thank you so
much thank you so much
[Music]
but words wisdom self-awareness empathy
gratitude these very tried and true
human attributes that are absolutely
driver of success in today's environment
straight up
see the background here then connected
to a machine
just a live stream
it was good start Behram idea will be
going
Peter stop
we get our cadence and content from up
there but we are not people
I got a bounce I love you guys hope you
have the best day your [ __ ] life